this is John and his friend Jane John
was sick last week but after taking some
antibiotics that were to prescribe to
him by his doctor he's feeling much
better now however it seems that Jane
has now contracted the same illness from
John but when prescribed with the same
antibiotics didn't seem to have any
effect on Jane's condition the reason
why Jane isn't getting better is because
the bacteria responsible for his
sickness developed a resistance to
debate a lactam antibiotic antibiotics
attack infections on or within the body
by either slowing its growth or killing
it directly these can be used in order
to sterilize a certain area or combat
any oncoming bacterial threat this is a
penicillin binding protein penicillin
binding proteins are proteins that build
up the cell wall beta-lactam antibiotics
work by attacking penicillin binding
protein which hinders cell wall
synthesis this damages the cell wall
which then causes the cell to die when a
bacterial container resistance gene dies
free DNA is released into the
surrounding environment if a bacteria
similar to the dead bacteria is within a
Sat vicinity it will be able to update
the naked DNA containing the resistance
gene for the beta-lactam antibiotics
once inside the bacteria the resistance
gene may be transferred from the naked
DNA to the chromosome of the host
bacteria by a process known as
homologous transformation over time the
bacteria may acquire enough of these
resistance genes to become resistant to
the beta-lactam antibiotics these
altered penicillin binding proteins can
now synthesize the cell wall and they
now have developed resistance for
beta-lactam antibiotics
therefore Jane will have to find a
different more expensive method of
treating her sickness using an
antibiotic when it isn't necessary will
only increase the chance that antibiotic
resistance will develop by preventing
bacterial resistance from developing we
will be able to save thousands of lives
from easily treatable infections and
viruses while scientists can modify
beta-lactam antibiotics to counter
bacterial resistance preventing
bacterial resistance is achievable
through many other ways such as not
taking antibiotics for sole illnesses
not sharing antibiotics discarding any
leftover antibiotics and taking the
dosage prescribed by your doctor so the
next time you were sick
think twice before asking your doctor to
prescribe you any antibiotics
you